CNN says one of its reporters was  stopped from covering the president's  trade announcement late this afternoon  in the Rose Garden and CNN has just  issued a statement quote today CNN White  House correspondent Caitlin Collins was  denied access to cover an open press  event at the White House after posing  questions to President Trump  earlier in the day as the network pool  reporter Collins was told by White House  deputy chief of staff for communications  bill Shine and press secretary Sarah  Sanders that her questions were  inappropriate they were not just because  the White House is uncomfortable with  the question regarding the news of the  day doesn't mean the question isn't  relevant and shouldn't be asked this  decision to bar a member of the press is  retaliatory in nature and not indicative  of an open and free press we demand  better as a member of the White House  press pool Fox stands firmly with CNN on  this issue of access so far no response  from the White House